On a very good day,
Mr.
Councilor,
are repeated,
at the same time,
in which this parliamentary group
They have brought you to this parliament,
he situation of lack of oxygen,
Aiming public health,
or that involves enormous presuppositions,
parish of Galicia and 2 Galicians,
during the months of his,
eh, August,
Alvarez's office,
me,
it's a medical reason,
eh,
all population was derived,
or Village Health Center,
how huge I brag that this supposes
for the usual David from neighboring Alonso,
to enter,
health care in albarello,
if not stop,
or rest,
due to oversaturation,
D.O.
Vilaza center.
It is also surprising,
Mr. Conselleiro,
this particular case,
because the head physician,
D.O.,
in the office of albarellos,
tinges rejection of his asitization,
3 years,
Mr.
Counselor,
or lack of foresight in 1 management capacity,
or declared intentionality,
pave the way for Alvarellos' office opeche,
Mr.
Councilor,
as you know,
he Berlin region,
Loita's strong example in favor of public health,
and against monsters,
D.O.
Popular Party,
we have clear examples,
Oberín,
11 breasts,
or Naye,
also Loita,
pediatrics, or aloite,
as well,
2 neighbors of Álvaro and Oscando,
bostedes,
tried not to reopen,
ye,
o Centro noano,
2 020,
I have to say, Yeca,
attempt at construction,
D.O.,
story of guasestión
by the D.O.
Popular Party,
always clashes head-on,
coarrealities,
eh,
what evidence,
eh, ecosfect,
you did not bother with nuance,
look at me,
on the 20th,
1 sleep, climbed
1 wrinkler,
D.O.
Alvarellos guarantee office,
not in 1 shade,
is 1 evidence that this professional is tinged with
responded to its asubilation,
3 years and you did not ingest their poison,
not to 1 shade,
it is 1 evidence
that 1 office of alvarello
more than 2 months in medical care
and now there are loose days of attention.
Not 1 shade,
en 1 evidence
what's next
up to 15 days to have 1 consultation,
be 1 doctor
as Mr.
Conselleiro demonstrates,
this image of application 2 Sergas,
non es 1 nuance,
en 1 evidence
and that with health care in albarello
is being referred to another health center,
with 1 major distance problem,
eh of oversaturation of the Center itself,
too,
not in 1 shade,
is 1 evidence,
Mr. Conselleiro,
this is the evidence,
that Funky Your account will not hold